[Music]
i'd love to just know as you're reading
from these religious and spiritual texts
whether it's scripture like the bible
or
any other source
how do you
pull from that what is your kind of
filtering mechanism could you give any
examples right because i think that
there are
there are people who can
hold
the let's just call it kind of
rationalist
mathematical
faculties while simultaneously having
faith-based
religion or spiritual practices they
don't have to be faith-based i mean you
could be a mystic with direct experience
it's very it's very different though to
integrate those things you can you can
have those two things co-exist in you
but some would view them as antithetical
to one another right so how do you how
do you filter and are there any examples
that come to mind of things you've
pulled from spiritual practices and
looked to port over into the scientific
a couple things
one
from the upanishads there's this saying
not that which the eye sees
but that whereby the eye can see
know that alone to be brahma the eternal
and not what people here adore
not that which the ear hears
but that whereby the ear can hear
know that alone to be brahma the eternal
not what people not that which the mind
thinks
but that whereby the mind can think
know that to be
so there's this distinction between
pure awareness
versus the contents of awareness
right
and
when i
realized that they were making that
distinction i look back at my math and i
realized that when i was writing down
these
mathematical models
of consciousness
probabilistic models and you have to
write down when you do that you have to
write down a probability space
so there's just this thing it's this
timeless thing
a probability space and then you have
the dynamics occurring on that space
so the mathematics itself also models
there's this
pure awareness beyond time
beyond the dynamics
that's the problem what i call the
probability space
and then there is the dynamical system
of the contents that appear and
disappear within that system so i
realized that that
there is this
really interesting
correspondence between the kinds of
things that they're saying
the contents there's pure awareness and
in some sense they'll they'll say what
you are is not any of your contents
you're not your body
you're not you're
the sound of your voice you're not your
possessions
none of that stuff is you you are the
pure awareness and and the pure
awareness is what survives death but not
necessarily any content
well that that does seem to
correspond pretty well with some of the
mathematics that i would wrote down just
because i had to write it down that way
that's just what you do when you write
down the mathematics and so so i find
these kinds of correspondences really
interesting and i want to pursue them
further the other one that i think is
really interesting is the insistence and
i get this
you get this in many of the spiritual
traditions but but
i see it really clearly like when
eckhart tolle is explaining these things
in his books like a new earth and the
power of now and so forth
he points out that
thinking
is not a very deep intelligence compared
to
the the realm of our reality beyond
thought
so in these spiritual traditions one of
the things you do in meditation is you
let go of thought
completely right
any thoughts that come up you
don't fight them but you don't
give them any engagement space
you they let them go and the the point
that they make is
that as you do that and it may take you
years to really
be able to do that
you are getting in touch with
an infinite intelligence
that is much much deeper than any
thought intelligence and in fact is the
source of all intelligence that comes
through our thoughts and so so if that's
right that that also makes sense from
from
this girdles and completeness theorem
point of view that i've been taking on
on this that is that consciousness
there's no description of it including
any conceptual thought description that
we can give that even scratches the
surface of the depths that girdles in
completeness theorem says is there so so
i see this correspondence again between
letting go of thought so there's this
really interesting thing we need thought
without words we wouldn't have this this
conversation right hard to podcast very
difficult hard to podcast with so so
it's not like words are bad and concepts
are bad the the question is how what is
the relationship between conceptual
systems and this intelligence that
transcends any conceptual system that's
the really interesting now the the
spiritual traditions will say it's a
pointer relationship where i'm using the
word aware as a pointer of course the
word aware don't take it too seriously
you can also call it consciousness
whatever but don't take the point or too
seriously and then some pointers are
really bad right so we have this notion
of good and bad pointers well so as a
scientist i'm going now that's really
interesting
what is what do we mean mathematically
by a good pointer versus a bad pointer
can we actually
take these ideas and make them more
rigorous so for example i'll just give a
really
simple concrete idea of kind of thing
that i'm talking about
the real numbers the real line you know
from minus infinity to infinity right so
that's a lot of numbers how about the
integers i'm the mathematician it sounds
like a lot of numbers it's a lot of
numbers right
and now just now just the integers from
minus infinity to infinity well
right
there's between zero and one there's a
whole bunch of real numbers right so
there's there's a sense in which the
integers aren't a very good
approximation to the real numbers right
there's so many real numbers between 0
and 1. 0 is not really telling me
anything about the integers between 0
and 1. so so
you could say that the integers are a
pointer to the real numbers
but it's a really bad pointer but now
take the rational numbers
a rational number is an integer divided
by an integer so you just take any two
integers you get a ratio those are
called the rational numbers and and it
turns out that the rational numbers are
what or what mathematicians call dense
in the real numbers you can approximate
a real number
as close as you want
with rational numbers
but not with integers
now it turns out there's just as many
rational numbers as there are integers
this sounds crazy i just so the number
of integers equals the number of
rational numbers
the integers are a bad pointer to the
real numbers but the rational numbers
are a good pointer to the real numbers
yeah they can approximate them so this
is the kind of thing that i see
can we take the spiritual idea that
what we are
is an infinite intelligence that cannot
be captured by any
finite conceptual system language for
example
speech thought
we have this notion of good
bad and worst pointers
can we
make this idea which has been for
thousands of years in the spiritual
traditions can we now you know dust it
off and and and make it serviceable in a
more rigorous way can we actually take
spirituality
and turn it into a scientific discipline
again which is not to desiccate it and
deprive it of of its life but to make it
precise and make it actually
serviceable actually make predictions
i would love
i mean my father was a minister in a
protestant fundamentalist church here's
what i would love the sermon the guy
gets up and his sermon is guess what we
just discovered mathematically about
spirituality this week you won't believe
it here's here's this new theorem about
spirituality
sign me up i would love to go to a
church like that where they're telling
you the new discoveries you know where
rigorous discoveries about good pointers
to you know here's here's how to think
about consciousness here's a better way
to do your meditation and we now have
this mathematics to explain why you
should do it this way and not that way i
would just love that kind of thing and i
think that science and spirituality
eventually could
collaborate
now question for you would would
spirituality
not at that point cease to be a useful
term in so much as
if if spirituality is and
please feel free to disagree with the
wording but
an attempt to describe
with
words these
clumsy imprecise labels
glimpses somehow if we if we look at the
mystic traditions mystical traditions
into this
fabric beyond space-time
like by the time they converge we will
have the the tools and the mathematics
to obviate the need for this word
spirituality is that nonsense that i'm
that i'm spouting well i think i think
that's a very natural question and and
my attitude is that
science itself is in the same boat
science will never have a theory of
everything
and science will always as newton put it
newton described near the end of his
life he described himself as
a little boy on the seashore
amusing himself with a little shell or a
pebble
when the vast ocean of truth lay
unexplored all before him
i think that's exactly right
and that's the right attitude that
science should have is that no matter
how far we
we
get with our scientific theories we have
to understand that we will always be
playing with pebbles on the seashore
just like newton was at least newton
was smart enough to understand that that
he was
playing with pebbles and so the fact
that the spiritual people are also just
playing with pebbles on the seashore but
they're pointing to the ocean beyond and
saying it's it's beyond conception
that's why i think the notion of the
pointers is really important yeah for
sure
good pointers versus bad pointers we we
can never get a theory
of that
but if the spiritual traditions are
right and if conscious realism is right
even though you can't
get a theory of it you can know it by
being it
right so you you you can't
know
that infinite intelligence through your
conceptual analysis you can get good
pointers to it and science can help us
get good pointers
but you can only
deeply know it by actually letting go of
thought and being it
but then
as a scientist
you can go there and be it
and then come back
with the goods
in your own conceptual system and make
progress in your science and that's what
i that's where i see this possibly going
scientists would actually learn
once we let go of our physicalism
would learn actually how that we we as
scientists are that infinite
intelligence
but our conceptual tools
are inadequate so we have to go into
that infinite intelligence in pure
silence
and then learn how to come back and take
our whatever insights we have gotten
into terms that we can actually write
down to mathematics and we go back and
forth that way so that's where i see
science and spirituality eventually
going
and this so it's going to require a
scientist to actually be not only a
master of mathematics and the theories
but also a master of letting go of
thought and actually going into the deep
intelligence if this whole approach is
correct
you